hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
n queen so this is a pretty famous
backtracking problem and we're finally
going to be solving it today
and this is marked as a hard problem but
i don't think it's super hard to come up
with what the solution would be at least
to come up with how to solve the problem
i think the hard part about this is
actually
implementing the code of this problem
because like i said it's backtracking so
basically we're just going to be doing a
brute force approach so the problem
statement is
we're given n queens we're given a board
of size
n by n a chess board right so the
dimensions are n by
n and we're also given n different
queens that we have to place somewhere
on this
board such that no two
queens ever attack each other so you
have to know a little bit about chess
so the way a queen can move is that
a queen is allowed to move in any
direction horizontally so it can move to
the left
or to the right it can move up or
down so it can move in all four
directions it can also move
diagonally so you know this diagonal
which i call
the positive diagonal because you can
see it's kind of a positive
slope right top right also it can move
in the negative diagonal direction which
i
which you know you can kind of tell is
going bottom right
so it can move in these different
directions
and that's kind of what makes it tricky
so we want to place
the queens in such a way that they don't
attack each other so right now you can
see this queen
is going left right top bottom
this diagonal and this diagonal right so
it's definitely not attacking any other
queen
this queen as well you can see it's
going up
left right down diagonal and you could
do that with all of the queens right i
don't want to make it too messy though
and then what we want to return is
actually these boards themselves so in
this case
we were given n equals four and you can
see that these
two different compositions are the ways
we could arrange the queens and then we
want to return that
as a list of strings each string
represents
one row in this board now the main thing
you notice initially is okay
since a queen can go horizontally or
vertically therefore
every queen has to be in a different
uh row right notice how every single
queen is in a different row that makes
sense because if we ever put two queens
in the same row then they'd be able to
attack each other right
so each queen has to go in a different
row
notice how each queen is also going in
a different column right each queen
in this case is in a separate column
because they can move
vertically we don't want them to attack
each other vertically
as well so that's pretty straightforward
i think but the hard part is
diagonals right notice how we have many
different diagonals in this
board let's just look at the positive
diagonals what i call the positive
diagonals the ones that can go
top to right so notice how
in this case we have many different
diagonals and in each of the cases
each queen is in a separate positive
diagonal right you can see that that's
the case
what about negative diagonals okay this
is one negative diagonal this is another
each queen is in a separate negative
diagonal
because we don't want any queens to
attack each other
diagonally so this is going to be the
part that's a little bit tricky to code
at least until you've seen it before but
it's actually really easy to implement
once you know the main idea
so now let me kind of show you how we're
going to apply backtracking to this
solution how we're going to apply the
brute force method to
get each valid arrangement of the end
queens
so what really really brute force idea
that you might have
is okay let's just choose okay we can
pick any of these positions in the
in the four by four grid let's put a
queen over here so that's the first
position we try okay
now let's try a different position right
for the second queen
let's try putting the queen in this
position right and then now we have all
these remaining choices let's keep
putting a queen in every single position
and trying that so this is one
arrangement then maybe we could take the
fourth queen and put it over here
etcetera etcetera
now why is there any reason to do that
that's a little bit too
brute force if you ask me there's a much
simpler way we can do it
right because for each queen instead of
having n
squared choices how about we just have n
choices because we know for sure each
queen is definitely going to be in a
different
row so first we can go like this we can
say
okay we can decide to put for this first
row itself right this first row we can
decide to put the queen in the first
position
or we could decide to put the queen in
the second position
or the third position or the fourth
position
whatever we do in that first row then
we're gonna move to the next row right
so now our goal is to find
a different location where we can put
the second queen
in this second row now we could try
putting it over here
or we could try putting it over here or
we could try putting it over here
but we can't put it over here why
is it that we can't put it here because
they're in the same column so
now you already can tell we're going to
need to be maintaining
the columns of whatever previous
queens that we've already placed we
don't have to maintain the rows though
right because i just showed you
why because every time we place a queen
we're gonna move to the next row
anyway until we get to the bottom right
and then we're gonna make sure
that we're placing the last queen in a
valid location
and if we are then we're done right so
we are gonna have to keep track of which
columns we place a queen
in and we're gonna have to keep track of
the positive
diagonals that we're placing a queen in
and we're gonna have to keep track of
the
negative diagonals that we're placing a
queen in and we can uh
keep track of all of these with a set
right
so a set can tell us a hash set can tell
us which column of zero
one two or three we have put a queen
already in
and we can do the same for a positive
diagonal
and a negative diagonal but i bet you're
wondering how can we do it
easily with positive and negative
diagonals right we don't have
indices for something like this right
what index does this diagonal belong to
and i'll show you there's a bit of a
pattern when it comes to diagonals
positive
and negative diagonals let's say we
start at the origin the top
left position and then we go diagonally
bottom right so this is what i'm going
to refer to as a
negative diagonal because from left to
right
we're end up going downwards right do
you
notice anything about this diagonal well
we're starting at 0
0 right the row and column are 0 0
as we move diagonally down we get to
this position right then the row and
column are
1 1 then we get to this position where
the row and column are 2 2. so notice
how
each time we're increasing the the
column value by one
and we're increasing the row value by
one as well
what does that tell us that tells us
along
this diagonal along this negative
diagonal
the computation rho minus
column is going to stay constant
over here right in this position if you
take the row minus the column we get
zero minus zero
that equals zero if you take the row
minus column in this position we get
two minus two that equals zero so we can
define
this particular negative diagonal as
being
the zero negative diagonal let's try it
out on a different negative diagonal to
see if our pattern holds
let's start over here at a different
position
row zero column two and then go
diagonally down
notice how whenever we're going
negatively diagonal we're
increasing the column by one and we're
increasing
the row by one so in this position
the row which is zero minus the column
was negative two right zero minus two is
negative two
when we get to the next position along
this diagonal we get
one minus three which is also negative
negative two so we can see that this
pattern holds the negative diagonal
along this
is going to be the negative one diagonal
the negative diagonal along
this path is going to be positive one
because we see one
minus zero is positive one so i just
drew out a few of the diagonals if you
want to visualize it you can see this
diagonal
is constant this diagonal is constant
this diagonal is constant etcetera
etcetera right
so that's how we're going to be doing
negative diagonals is there a similar
pattern we can use for positive
diagonals let's see
so let's say we started our positive
diagonal over here
we can see the row is three the column
is zero and then we go diagonally top
right right we go
up in this direction now notice when we
do go in this direction
we're moving to the right we're
increasing the column by one
but we're decreasing the row
by one so we can't use row minus column
for positive diagonals right because
it's not going to stay constant
over here the row minus column is going
to be three over here the row minus
column is going to be
1 so it doesn't work if we do row minus
column
but notice since we're increasing the
going in this direction but we're
decreasing
the row that means row plus column
is going to stay the same right the sum
of these two values is going to stay the
same because we're
we're decrementing one but we're
increasing the other
for example in this position row plus
column is three
in this position row plus column is also
three
right so it's going to be three all the
way what about
this diagonal does it also work well
three plus
one that's four in this position
two plus two that's four and this is
also going to be four so you can see
positive diagonals can be determined
with r
plus c turns out that these three sets
are the only information we need then we
can
brute force start placing queens how's
the algorithm going to go
like i mentioned we're going to try each
of the four positions
in the first row right and for each of
them so the decision tree is going to
look something like this right we'll try
a queen in position 0. we'll try a queen
in position 1
position 2 position 3 right and this is
all for the first row and we'll do the
exact same
thing continuously right for if we put a
queen here
then could we pl then we're gonna you
know try a queen in all the other four
places so
two three now if we place the queen here
that means we put a queen here so then
could we put a second queen in the same
column
no that's how we're going to know how
are we going to detect that we can't do
this
we're going to see that a queen has
already been placed in the same column
set so we're not going to do that right
so we can't place a queen here
what about position 1 well it's clearly
not in the same
column right why shouldn't i be able to
place a queen over here well
it turns out that it's already been
added to the negative diagonal
this position means the negative
diagonal is zero row minus column is
zero
so this position is also row minus
column
zero that means the negative diagonal
has already been used so we also
can't put a queen in this second
position so this
path in our decision tree also does not
work can we put a queen
over here in this position yes we can it
doesn't
overlap with the positive diagonal and
it doesn't overlap
with the negative diagonal and they're
not in the same column right so we can
continue
this one and we can also continue in
this one right it's also not in the same
positive or negative diagonal
also not in the same column so that's
kind of how the algorithm is going to
work
i'm not going to draw the entire
decision tree because i think you
probably get the point these
three sets are going to give us all the
information we need
okay so like i mentioned the the three
sets are going to be all the information
we need we have a column set we have a
positive diagonal set and remember the
positive diagonal is determined let's
just place a comma is determined by
r plus c and the negative
diagonal is determined by r minus c
so let's just make sure we remember that
when we're actually writing our code
r minus c for the negative diagonal and
we're going to have a result which is
basically going to tell us all possible
end queen solutions and we're also going
to maintain a
board so initially i'm just going to
make the board a
array of let's say and by the way i
didn't mention this but a dot
is basically indicating an empty
location so this multiplied by
n is going to determine a row how many
rows are we going to have well
for i in range n right it's an n by
n board so i'm just initialing a board
with
periods or dots in every single position
so then
we can define our backtracking recursive
function
and remember we're going to be doing it
row by row so initially we're going to
start at
row 0 then we're going to go to row 1
row 2 all the way until we get to row
n row n is our base case that means
we're out of bounds that means we
already completed every single row
so if we ever reach this position where
rho is equal to n
that means we were able to find a valid
n queen solution
so what can we do well of course we're
going to return but before we return
we're going to add whatever the current
board is and we're going to add it to
the result
but we are going to make a copy of this
board because we're still going to use
it in
subsequent function calls for this
recursive function so we're going to
make a copy of this board
and we're also going to change the
formatting the way they want it each row
is not going to be an array
each row is going to be a string so
basically for each row here we're just
going to join
each substring together so let's make a
copy of this board
which we can do by taking four
let's say row in the board each row
we're going to take each row and then
join it together so
we can do that in python like this empty
string dot
join this entire row together
and then doing this we'll have a copy of
the board where each row is basically
joined together right
and then we're going to take that copy
and append it to the result so
result.append
copy i mean i'm sure there's different
ways you can do this if you're using
java or c
plus plus this is just an easy way to do
it in python so if we did not reach the
base case that's when we're gonna
continue
so we're gonna go through every single i
in
range of n right we're gonna try every
single position
in the current row that we're at we're
gonna see which
positions are we allowed to place a
queen inside
and this i actually refers to the column
so i'm going to change it to for
c and range n so basically if c is
in column meaning it's already been used
in this column or
r plus c is already in the positive
diagonal
which means the positive diagonal has
already been used or
if the negative diagonal r minus c has
already been used
that's how we know we have to skip this
position so what i'm going to say
is continue if that's the case that
means we're not allowed to use this
column row position but if we are
allowed to use this position
let's do exactly that then we can do a
backtracking
call you know do the same thing
backtracking call let's go to the next
row but before we do that we know we
have to actually update all of our sets
right because we we weren't using
this uh combination but now we are using
it so we have to say
column dot add this column and we have
to say positive diagonal
dot add row plus column
and we have to say negative diagonal add
row
minus column so that's just kind of some
of the pre-work that we have to do
and we also have to update the board
itself right we have to say okay at this
position in the board row
column let's set it equal to a queen
not a dot anymore so that's what we're
going to do before we start our
recursive backtracking solution
and after we're done we have to do the
cleanup that is required in most
in most backtracking solutions right so
we have to basically do what we just did
here and
undo all of it for the next iteration of
the loop
so i'm just going to copy and paste this
because we're literally just going to be
having to rewrite every line so instead
of
adding all of these to the set i'm going
to be removing all of these to the set
right that's kind of what backtracking
means
where we're backtracking from what we
just did to seeing if maybe multiple
solutions exist
right that's the brute force element of
this so we initially set this equal to a
queen
let's set it back equal to an empty
space or a dot
in this case and that's really it we
have no return condition
in this backtracking so once this loop
is done executing then we're done with
the entire function so now
outside of here all we have to do is
call our backtracking function
passing in row 0 and then once that is
done
we will have updated our result so our
result should contain
everything we need so then we can just
be able to go ahead and say okay return
the result
so you can see that the solution does
work and it is pretty dang efficient
even though it's a backtracking brute
force approach so i hope this was
helpful
if it was please like and subscribe that
supports the channel
a lot and i'll hopefully see you pretty
soon thanks for watching